okay cool no it's okay okay so so we are
live uh i'm with uh jen we're talking
about her movement
hashtag fantasy and her webcam is not
working right now so
when when you talk i see a picture of
you at least i don't know what the
audience sees but uh
whatever
my pictures you know better than nothing
i guess than blank screen
so how are things what's going on
they're good they're good i'm excited i
um
i
i've been working on
several blog posts and got one up i know
my goal was one a week and it didn't
happen but um yeah but i'm excited
because i've made some progress on
twitter
um i put up a video almost the same day
i think the last time we talked and
that's gotten some views
and yeah i'm just excited i'm moving
forward
and i got a facebook page up
yes that was the other goal yes yes
exactly now are you posting to
everything
um i post i posted both of my um blogs
my blog posts on facebook and i put
another um i posted something else that
i was inspired by by somebody else um
but i haven't been doing like quotes or
anything like that that i um
that i probably should start doing more
of like you know kind of like you do
with you know in the cool graphic
picture or something like that
yeah i mean it doesn't it doesn't have
to it doesn't have to look fantastic it
doesn't have to be a picture you're
sharing i can see the thing you shared
mark twain
today yeah you've been sharing some
stories you've been sharing you've been
more way more active on twitter than
before
yes i have been it's awesome because i'm
interacting more with other people and
i can't remember actually one of my um
tweets got like over 300 views i got a
little thing from twitter saying that i
got 300 views it was the one where you
um you
i can't remember names like dooga ninja
it was some comedian and you um made a
joke about him having a fantasy or
something and i replied saying he said
something about night cheese and i was
like
nightmares or something like that
yeah that was that was fun
yeah so anyway a few a few more
pardons that was your best tweet
well that was one of the ones that got
over 300 views yeah wow okay cool hey
you never know what's gonna hit yeah no
kidding
yeah okay this is great so
so how can we keep the blog thing going
well that's a good question i think i
need to um
have some like like sort of ready to go
ahead of time which i now i feel like i
had that because i already have a couple
more in the hopper i just have to put
finishing touches on them
and i love how last time you suggested
to
use you know tweet from you know quoting
from my own blog post and i did that
like you know i was able to get like a
couple weeks worth of you know tweets
from that along with you know other
quotes from other people
so
yeah that was helpful and um and then
the one i just posted yesterday or day
before yesterday um i quoted something
on twitter yesterday about it and
somebody else commented on it back
already so that was cool too
good hey it's happening yeah it is yeah
i'm excited
so okay i'm looking at the blog right
now this graphic that you have with the
text on it is that
is that what is that what's the picture
there yeah it's basically just a little
fantasy story so it's it's sort of
related to
the blog post but sort of not it sort of
stands on its own
and that was just an idea i had to kind
of like
you know illustrate people you know what
a little fantasy could be like so with
each blog post i'm trying to have a
little fantasy story
and then you know have it sort of relate
to the blog post but it's not it's not
directly related if that makes sense
okay i'm just
quickly scanning it now
can you have it
can the fantasy have um
can the fantasy have a uh
a teachable lesson included in it
yeah
well this one sort of did so this one
my lesson and this one was like hey if
you have a fantasy it could come true so
this little fantasy
is about this person who kind of has a
dream
about seeing somebody you know that she
hasn't seen in a while that she really
misses
and then she wakes up and and then all
of a sudden you know or she's having a
fantasy it's not really a dream she's
having a fantasy is the idea and then
she kind of wakes up from this fantasy
and
gets a phone call or gets a message from
this person
okay
but are you thinking more like have it
be a little more obvious
because it's a little subtle it's subtle
yeah it's subtle
is this hard for you to make
no no it's not hard for me to make okay
um i know some people are more into the
graphics and everything than others um
no what what i was thinking was
if you could brand this and have it be
so that the picture could be shared on
its own
right okay
right like people may look at that
because when you post to facebook
i saw the post and this is what shows up
as the picture
yeah you want people
sharing
your stuff
yeah
what helps is
if there's
if there's a
i read this story and it makes me
want to change something in my life
okay
right so if the lesson is your dreams
can come true
then i
should have i should read this and at
the end feel like
hey you know what my dreams can come
true
right right yeah
or whatever teachable lesson you want to
have included here because then what i
might do is
obviously share the whole blog post and
and the blog
relates to
you know the picture yeah
but also i might just share the picture
okay
right
i see what you're saying would it be um
well one of the things i did do is i set
up a pinterest page too and i that's
exactly what i did i posted both of
those pictures just kind of on their own
and then they link to
the blog post so if someone were to
check it out they could link they could
click on it and then and then go to the
blog post
right okay so look i wonder would it
would it be better if it was like more
obvious though like that i'm stating
what the lesson is sort of at the
beginning
yeah like i would maybe
this is what i would do so it's just an
idea but i would start with
uh
your one
in a couple words what this lesson is
about
so it's about so like you have your post
live your fantasy that's the name of the
post right right right okay so that's
that may be the name of the
like that may be the name of the on the
graphic too or maybe you know your
dreams can come true or whatever it is
like a quick couple words so i know in
advance what this is all about
okay
and then ending with something in your
style that
makes it hit home
for me
so like i'm reading this this story and
then
like how does this impact my life
right like you know like sometimes
thinking of those this commercials and
videos where
um
you see a touching story of uh of a
father and a son
and you know maybe the the father is
dying of cancer and so the son is now
taking care of him and the videos may
show
when he was a baby you know his father
did so much for him and now he's giving
back you watch that
and
you feel like you want to go hug your
dad right like right right
so like there's a there's a story there
and it's a it's a teachable lesson for
me to go haven't
do something in my life right go have a
connection i would love right like so
you take me on this journey
you tell me what it's about then you
take me on this journey at the end i
want to do something in my life because
i read your story okay
i mean yeah
right they'll share it on
they'll share the blog post but they'll
share just that picture yeah yeah
okay
so maybe that's an intention you go in
with for the next blog post give it a
shot see if you like it i think you have
a good impact um like what change and
maybe it's a personal thing for you
you know like maybe you want to feel
closer to your mom and so you write this
story of as somebody goes on this
journey and at the end you feel closer
to your mom or you want to go do
something
um
so you start with that intention
often comes from something personal in
your life
you tell a story to take somebody on the
journey and then you end with uh that
feeling that i want to go do something
positive
okay
can you see me i can i can totally see
yeah okay good it's funny i feel like
i'm just talking to you so it must be
weird for you to see my picture but like
i feel like you can see me like normal
it's okay you're smiling it's good yeah
you can hear my smile right
okay cool so
yeah that's great
um and then you end with
become a living fantasy one share the
love okay i see and then get the free
updates sign me up okay
cool um
yeah so so
like you develop your rhythm you got to
schedule this in
how long does it take you to write this
well um
that's a good question because i was
like i said i was working on like three
at the same time and trying to decide
which one to post first okay that was
kind of my problem i was being but now
that i i can schedule them out it
probably takes me a week if it's good
like if it's good i kind of work on it
over a week so i would really like to
post one a week you know sometimes i'm
like if i'm in the flow you know it
comes like in a couple hours you know
how that is yeah
yeah i mean they don't have to be
as long each time yeah
right so for example i have a newsletter
right uh you are you online you're on my
newsletter yeah i'm on your newsletter
list yeah
i have a newsletter and it's often just
what i am
feeling and going through with some
something happening i have an opinion
until i share it but often i don't
not often but sometimes i don't have
time to
to write it like the birthday one yeah
the one just came out right yeah it was
super short right it's like hey i don't
have time to write my newsletter because
it's my birthday here's a video that
people may enjoy i got
that was one of the most
responses i've gotten of
any of my newsletters right because it
was cool because people got to see the
video of all the people that you know
are you know are in your life and that
was cool yeah and people saying happy
birthday and whatever right so you know
the post doesn't always have to be
super long
yeah but
having a consistent schedule helps like
people come to expect my newsletter
every week right it comes like on every
wednesday or something or tuesday i
can't remember now it says it's
wednesday morning early morning five
o'clock
okay
so having a consistent schedule so i
know like usually i write it on mondays
um sometimes tuesdays if my mondays are
crazy but usually i write it on mondays
um
so
like having a schedule
that's a great idea okay
so even if you can't post a full
usual blog post you might even like that
could be a great story and it lets us
learn a little bit more about
you and what's going on in your life
yeah
i totally see what you're saying i agree
yeah because i have been super like
swamped with some changes going on in my
life which is great um it's all for the
good but it's just it's been
overwhelming as part of why i didn't get
everything done so you're right i could
have i could have posted about that
really quick and you're right probably
would have
gotten some response yeah like hey i'm
super swamped i'm
like tell me what's happening in your
life quickly you're right right yeah
give me fantasy
people people will like that that's a
personal you're not you're not perfect
right yeah you're living your fantasy
but it's not perfect and you are
crunched for time too and
right personal connection and then next
week you go back to your regular
schedule
okay
okay so from this you're going to take
this is going to line up tweets for you
right this blog post you made now this
is going to be your tweets for the next
little bit yeah for the next week yeah
there's a there's a big chunk of tweets
i could pull from that for sure okay
cool how are you so i see you're you're
posting from other people you've got the
mark twain quotes other quotes
uh you're retweeting what other people
are doing which is great have you
figured out a twitter schedule or you're
just posting you go online when you feel
like it or how is that working out for
you yeah i'm probably i'm going on like
maybe every morning and every afternoon
every evening ish probably just for like
5-10 minutes and i usually try and post
like
every other time like something that's
you know from my heart you know and then
something that's like a quote from
someone else
okay like every other time and then you
know i like to interact with people if
they've you know sent me whatever sent
me a message
um
so yeah that's for me that's really easy
because i'm just gonna do five minutes
you know
and i already have some quotes that i
pull like i probably spend
you know some time each week to pull
quotes from them that i that i like and
i kind of have a
you know swipe file to do that from so
um
so yeah so would you suggest our is
there do you see a difference between
response you get
i'm sure you do on twitter versus
facebook and what works well on each
platform um
so
facebook is definitely a picture economy
right so
pictures work
wow so i would take some of the stuff
that you're posting like there was that
video that you posted i don't know so
it's a picture of the the craigslist
ad right yeah did you post it on your
facebook page no i still could yeah i
love that one you could right like
anything that's picture related
i would put up on the facebook page okay
the pictures tend to do really well
there
um
how often are you posting on your
facebook page
um not very often and i haven't really
promoted it very well either i mean i
haven't really invited friends to like
it or anything yet um i kind of wanted
to get more on there before i did that
but i think i might just start if i have
the friends on that will make me post
more often probably yeah i would post
and even like the mark twain quote you
put up you can post that on your
facebook page yeah yeah okay
post the
post the
so the gen thoughts you want to post
right the quotes so these quotes these
tweets you're coming out with over the
next week post that on twitter uh sorry
on facebook
okay well
i'm gonna write that down post here post
twitter
um so all your gen thoughts all your
quotes anything is a picture things that
you find interesting and want to share
you could post all that on facebook the
the retweeting and the comments keep
that to twitter
right
right like the golden mirror
whatever like that's fine like retweet
that but keep that
keep that on twitter
okay um the facebook
facebook is better when you can schedule
it out too so
a post
last um the half-life is like three or
four hours yeah so you don't want to
post like three things in an hour and
then nothing for the rest of the day
right right and just space it out now
you can you can use i use hootsuite
you can use you can use other software
to schedule it if you want so if you're
spending you know 10 15 minutes in the
morning you could post three things but
schedule them so they're not all coming
out
at nine in the morning
yeah they're coming out over time right
i see you use what are you social um
no
golden that was golden miracle yeah yeah
yeah okay
um so yeah you might go on and say oh
that's a cool tweet i want to retweet
that or i have my quote for the day and
as a famous quote for the day
uh you could use hootsuite to schedule
it out so it goes
you know three different times and that
can go to your your
your twitter page and your facebook page
together
okay
okay
so um that's definitely a good start i
definitely start posting some more stuff
there and if you find pictures and
things that you like you can post that
on your facebook page too
okay the other thing i would think about
and this has worked well for me
um
is having a champion for usa champion of
the week
okay
and what i do is i do a champion of the
day i have a small business champion of
the day and i you know i think part of
your responsibility once you've
discovered your movement is to go help
other people who are
doing the same thing
right
same battle as you do and so
for me anybody who's supporting
entrepreneurship i try to help them out
and i want them to be successful in
doing what they're doing and so i have a
small business champion of the day where
i recognize
people or companies who are doing great
things to support entrepreneurs and i
just recognize them so give them give
them promotion to my audience um some of
them are people um like from the sharks
tank right who are
right for entrepreneurs and investing
some of the people who i've done
business with who have a great attitude
towards entrepreneurs but people may not
know anything about them it's just a
personal twitter account but i'll still
shout out to them yeah
and so i do that once a day now you
may not have enough tweets that like if
you do once a day may be too
overwhelming but once a week recognize
somebody who
who is part of the fantasy movement
right who yeah supporting others who
post great stuff it could be somebody
who you know personally in your life
who's just doing great things or
somebody who you've
who you follow online and you love their
stuff
okay recognize them and what it does is
it helps i mean it's good karma it
spreads the love
you know people now start to follow
these guys and i mean at the start a lot
of them may be more famous than you are
right now have a bigger following that's
okay
um but it also gets you on their radar
screen
and
they'll say oh that's really cool thanks
jen i'm gonna and they'll go and check
out your twitter account and see what
you're posting
yeah like what they see they may retweet
they may interact to help start to build
relationships
um
and you're with like-minded people
trying to do kind of the same thing have
the same goal
so
i would try to pull one a week to start
and see how that goes
um people who you think are just doing a
good job you want to recognize
yeah
i dig it that's exciting
if you want
um it's just a small business
champion of the week
the name like at whoever and then thank
you for everything you do to help
entrepreneurs something like that yeah
make it make it fit your own style sure
make it fit fantasy or imagination or
dreams or something like that yeah i see
what you're saying i mean most of the
people who if they see that they're
saying
like they're totally in tune with it
right yeah they love it they're
you know they agree with you and and
hopefully they'll love following you on
twitter too and sharing your stuff
yeah
i love that idea that's a really good
idea and i can think of people already
that i've seen on there that are both
bigger and smaller i mean now smaller
but just have you know less followers
than me yeah
yeah that's great cool i mean that can
repeat too like every three months or
four months or whatever if you build a
list
yeah
so cool okay cool i dig it yeah
um
okay how about our video when's the next
video coming out
um
i well definitely before the next time
we talk for sure um
i could probably do one this week
in the next video
it could be a blog post too so instead
of writing a blog post per week you
could do a video
yeah
so you spend that i mean obviously you
have limited time right so
you spend that time working on the video
and that becomes your post instead of
just doing the
right
that's a good idea at least to have a
goal to maybe do a post every other week
in a video every other week and then
um
if i do more than that great
but at least i'm working on one of the
other each week
okay so one video
one video
every other week
one blog post every other week cool
yeah it's good i i think it's good for
you to experiment with both it'll get
your
experience up and you'll see what people
are reacting to and you can still take
things that you say in your video and
turn them into tweets for your content
yeah
yeah you're right i totally can
yeah
you know what too if you have um
i'm looking at that picture again on
your blog at the top of your post yeah
if you create uh like if that's your
style which it is you have your font
your colors everything on there if you
add your um
branding on there
uh-huh you put your logo at the bottom
right or something or website something
something branded yeah when you tweet
you could tweet
the picture as well as the quote well
that's a good idea
like you can make each tweet on that
format as long as it's not too time
consuming for you to do that
no i can do that
then when you post to facebook
like you could do your mark twain quote
too right you could put it on this
format yeah you don't even need a
picture of mark twain just
put it on this and put your
much logo on the bottom
um
and then that's that becomes more
shareable because people love sharing
pictures
yeah
that's a cool idea do you you know one
of the things um
do you ever like
twitter
you probably don't you don't tweet out
your newsletter or anything like that
but you do your videos you you have
links on your tweets about right
yeah my newsletter i i don't because i
keep it from my
core audience yeah well whatever
i use aweber and they do have an option
to
to they make a web version of it that
you could tweet out and people could go
check out right but i do tweet out my uh
the videos that come out twice a day i
do a video and there they get tweeted
out to my account
okay
because that's one of the things i was
sort of like yesterday when i pulled a
quote from my blog post i didn't put a
link to the blog post in there and i was
sort of like debating like will this get
more response if it you know if it's
more organic has a you know as a gen
thought quote unquote or is will it be
better if it i mean i think it's
probably probably both i could have some
that have links to my blog post and some
that just you know
stand alone
i see what you're asking yeah usually so
i found you get a much better response
rate when you're not putting
the link in yeah the picture
okay if you look at my twitter as a
something to model look at that go out
um so what's on my account now
so there's a quote by um jill koenig who
wrote in results will show up when you
do
and then the link
the link is a picture
so
it's a picture that
has a sun rise or sunset and then it has
my brand name at the bottom
okay
that works way better
than this this is actually from my blog
so if you go to my blog
picture
it works way better than
having a link to my blog
okay
so i would that's what i would recommend
have the quote put the whole quote in
there
ideally it's short enough that people
can still retweet it and include your
name in it because you lose characters
when that happens
also have the picture that gets uploaded
to twitter
uh that people can see and share
okay
yeah like the person who responded to my
tweet yesterday i felt like if i'd had
the link that she might not have
you know interacted with me versus if
you know if i just had a picture is a
great idea okay yeah you'll get a better
response because i used to do it the
other way and it's not as many um
uh
you don't get as much a response
okay
so somebody wrote in
chefs chefs tv writes in to say good day
sorry for joining late
love it thank you for joining chefs
he's still here that's good
thanks for joining
um
so it's good it's good i'm
uh i've been really happy with uh
the the progress you've been making on
twitter it's great to see
that you're you know posting some stuff
you're experimenting you have some fun
with it and uh if we keep following the
plan
you're gonna get much better results i'm
excited for you yeah yeah it's building
it's building for sure yeah i think
since we've talked and spent about a
month but i think i probably have
another 100 followers or pretty close so
that's not too bad not too shabby
up up and away it's good that's right
okay so um you got the plan for next
month and then if you want to book a
time in uh
in june okay we'll do it we'll see how
you're doing okay
sounds good hopefully i'll have a camera
working by then
hopefully the webcam will work
yes i think i'm gonna get a new computer
by then so that's another goal of mine
put it on the list
get new computer
all right thanks jen have a great one
great to see you cheers bye